Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea makers...
We can really change
the world together.
Aaaaaah!
Narrator: ...the ones
who determine their own fate.
Whoo!
We got a deal!
Narrator: We celebrate
entrepreneurs.
I want you all to think...
"Who's next?"
Narrator: This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
Alex Rodriguez joins the tank.
When I was a 10‐year‐old boy,
I had two dreams.
I wanted to be
a Major League Baseball player,
and I wanted to be a CEO
of a major company.
This baseball legend is also
a business heavy‐hitter,
with over 20 years of experience
in entrepreneurship
and investing.
There's smart capital,
and you're not gonna find
smarter capital
than these Sharks.
Yeah.
We actually just hit
our million‐dollar mark
in gross sale.
What?
Did you read my book?
[ Chuckles ]
The ones that have made me
the most money
have always been
the craziest.
We are...
All: The Gronks!
My dogs are barking.
O'Leary: I'm a huge fan.
But I want to make money.
I'm a Shark.
I would give you
a million dollars for 10%.
"Boom" goes the dynamite.
♪♪
Narrator: First into The Tank is
a sweeter way to eat
a popular snack.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Makenzie Marzluff,
and I'm from Los Angeles.
I'm seeking $600,000 in exchange
for 12% of my company,
Delighted By.
Nearly everyone has
a sweet tooth, right?
When you go
to the grocery store,
you walk down aisles
of tempting treats.
It's nearly impossible
to walk out
without giving in.
Well, what if I told you,
you can now treat yourself
guilt‐free?
Insert Delighted By ‐‐
home of the original
dessert hummus.
[ Greiner laughs ]
O'Leary:
Dessert hummus?
You heard me right ‐‐
dessert hummus.
It's a dip,
still made from chickpeas,
but just in sweet flavors.
To be honest,
it tastes less like hummus
and more like cookie dough,
but healthy,
and we're always 100% vegan,
gluten‐free, non‐GMO,
with less than 5 grams of sugar
per serving.
I know that first‐timers
may be skeptical,
but the proof is in the taste,
which is why we need your help.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to dip in
and be delighted
by a sweet deal.
‐Totally.
‐Bring it on.
‐Let's have it.
‐[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Will you get me mine?
This one's me?
Thank you, Makenzie.
You are welcome.
That's great.
Marzluff: So, let me tell you
what you're tasting.
You have our brownie‐batter
hummus on a pretzel,
then you have our
snickerdoodle hummus an apple.
Wow, weird.
Next is vanilla bean hummus
served on a graham cracker,
then you have
our choc‐o‐mint hummus
as a healthy frosting
on a cupcake.
Oh, my goodness.
This [bleep] is good.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
And then you have
our chocolate‐chip hummus
served on a spoon,
proving that you can have your
cookie dough and eat it, too.
Mmm.
It really is a healthy
alternative to a dessert.
Makenzie, how'd you come up
with the idea?
So, my background's
in nutrition and culinary.
I was going to
a Super Bowl party,
and I just wanted to create
a cookie dough dip
that was healthy.
So, I thought, why not put
chickpeas in the blender?
And when I brought it
to the party,
everyone literally thought
it was cookie dough.
I said, "No, no, no.
It's hummus."
It's still the same amount
of chickpeas.
I have to admit,
it's damn good.
Yeah.
‐I mean, it's really good.
‐Thank you.
‐It is delicious.
‐Thank you so much.
You have a very big price
on the business.
You must have
enormous sales.
You know, we launched
to shelves 13 months ago,
and we actually just hit
our million‐dollar mark
in gross sales.
‐What?!
‐Wow!
‐Good for you!
Because you're going
into the refrigerated sector,
which is very hard
to get into.
It is.
You're kicking somebody else
out to get that space.
Yeah, so, we're in
1,200 stores right now.
I rented a van,
and I drove up and down
seven states in the east coast
to all 88 Wegmans stores.
By yourself?
Twice ‐‐ by myself.
I was literally sleeping
on coolers of hummus.
You're a beast,
Makenzie.
‐That's crazy.
‐That's really crazy.
Marzluff: So, what I hear
from the buyers is,
"You are the only person
innovating in this category."
Yes.
I've been told over
and over again
this is the only innovative
thing in the category itself.
Are you sold side‐by‐side
to other hummusses?
Yes, right now,
we're merchandising
next to regular hummus.
The problem is you're not
a competitor to hummus.
♪♪
This has nothing to do
with hummus.
But it's a competitor
from the buyer level, right?
Rodriguez: Makenzie,
how much money have you invested
to get this business
started?
Personally,
around 20 grand,
and we've raised to‐date 400k
from friends and family.
At what valuation
did you raise that at?
The last round was
4 million.
What do you think
it's gonna look like in revenue
this year?
I'm projecting
$1.5 million in sales.
‐Okay.
‐That's conservative.
You value the business
at $5 million.
You're asking me
to pay 33 times
the potential of what
you could make this year.
There are other players that
have co‐packers in hummus
that could emulate
what you're doing
that already have distribution
in a much wider basis.
Okay, let's look
at all the big guys
that are purchasing
hummus companies.
Okay.
So, we've got Pepsi.
But you're not
a hummus company.
But we're taking
their shelf space.
Rodriguez: Makenzie,
in a business like this,
I would love to pay
five to eight times EBITDA,
or net earnings,
okay?
You're coming here,
and you're asking for almost,
like Kevin said,
north of 30 times.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Look, you've been successful
in raising at $4 million,
it's friends and family.
Now you're in front
of real investors.
Are you going to have
any flexibility on valuation?
No.
Rodriguez: Makenzie,
all due respect,
I just want you to keep in mind
as you move forward,
not every capital
is the same.
There is some capital
called smart capital,
and you're not gonna find
smarter capital
than these Sharks.
That's why I feel like
I'm giving a fair valuation,
because I know that
what this category ‐‐
no, the industry requires.
What do you feel like
you're missing?
In terms of a team?
Yeah, just to get
to where you want to go?
Like, if you look at what
I'm projecting in terms
of what I want to use
this capital for,
we're looking at some
operations support.
What my ‐‐ I have brokers
in the midwest.
They'll tell me, you know,
if you had a VP of sales,
that would be really helpful,
because they can direct
you strategically.
Would you use this
to hire one?
Yes.
But you've hired
no one yet.
Look, we're 13 months in.
Like, I'm ready to build a team.
I'm here.
Like, I need some help
with building that team.
You don't have even
a beginning team
of people
to support you.
I did hire an intern,
but it just wasn't perfect
in terms of excellence.
You know what I learned
about delegating,
and I learned it
very young?
80% is good enough.
I think you're gonna
have a hard time
multiplying yourself
hiring people,
knitting them into a team,
and building relationships.
I don't hear any indication
that that's your forte.
I'm gonna trust my instinct.
I'm out.
Thank you.
It's a fabulous
product.
The problem is,
is the money burnt.
You actually have to have
a very big, wide distribution,
but at the same time,
it requires a ton of money.
I'm out.
Cuban: How open
to change are you?
Because when I look
at this,
I think the hardest
possible place to sell it
is in grocery stores,
because you have to sample it
to get people ‐‐
for someone to say,
"Wow, this is amazing."
Have you looked at retail
at all, opening up a store?
I've thought about it.
Of what, Mark?
Mark, you're thinking like
an ice cream store?
Yes.
I think
that's a crazy idea.
Exactly, thank you.
The ones that have made me
the most money
have always been
the craziest.
Okay, you and I would
never agree on this valuation.
I'm not gonna fight with you
about that.
I'll loan you
the $600,000...
at 11%,
and I'll take 6% of the business
for doing that.
♪♪
Makenzie, the thing for me is,
I always look for things
that are healthy, taste good,
that are gluten‐free,
but the equity is
an issue.
In order for me to do it,
it would have to be
a 600k for 25%.
How 'bout those
chickpeas?
Makenzie, basically,
he cut your valuation in half.
I want to move up
your balance sheet.
I want to be a lender.
Mark is willing to be
an equity investor,
but he wants 25%
of the company.
I'm willing to do both,
once we hit our benchmarks ‐‐
That's the difference.
And so, when, you said,
we meet those benchmarks...
Right, then cash
will be available.
‐Cash will be available?
‐Yeah.
I don't mind le‐‐
I do it with all my companies.
Do you believe that we can
build it to, like,
$80 million valuation?
‐Yes.
Makenzie, this is not
supposed to be easy.
You've got to decide.
Okay.
It's a simple decision.
Do you want to sell 25%
of your company?
Don't force her.
The challenge in this is,
you have a genius product,
but you don't have
a company yet, right?
Yeah.
And, so,
it's gonna take all that.
So, you're saying,
you're gonna help with that?
Yes, all of it.
Soup to nuts.
Everything ‐‐
I've done it before.
‐Okay, you have a deal.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh! Good one!
‐Whoo!
‐Good decision.
‐Congrats.
Thank you so much.
We'll make this work.
Thank you.
Congrats, Makenzie.
♪♪
Marzluff: My vision is
that in four years' time,
someone's at your house,
and you offer them hummus,
and they say,
"Oh, is it sweet or savory?"
We're actually creating
a new category,
and I believe that, with Mark,
we can do that.
I'm telling you ‐‐ we open up
a little retail store...
The reason why
I like it, Mark,
is because you're just probably
need 600 square‐feet.
More than that.
That's a bad idea.
No, listen to me.
Listen to me.
You go, and you take
a busy thoroughfare ‐‐
"Honey, let's not have
ice cream ‐‐
let's go and have
a little bit of hummus
at that other place."
Yeah, you watch.
You watch.
♪♪
I was born in New York City.
My parents are both immigrants
from Dominican Republic.
My dad left us
when I was about 10,
and then I was raised by
a single mother here in Miami.
My mother was a workhorse.
She would wake up at 7:00,
drop us off at school,
go be a secretary, and then
go serve tables at night.
It was quite an inspiration
to watch her
grind it out every day.
Luckily for me, I had
the Boys and Girls Club,
where I learned
how to play baseball,
and I had a place to do my
homework every day after school.
Graduated high school
and I got a scholarship
to the University of Miami,
but then the Mariners
came calling.
They drafted me
number‐1 overall.
First two things I did ‐‐
buy my mother a house,
and buy her a car.
I think, to this day, they are
the happiest days of my life.
The highlight of my career was
that I played
for almost 23 years,
but I was always thinking
about what's next.
I started my business career
in my early 20s out of fear.
I saw so many of my peers
get injured.
That's why I started A‐ROD CORP.
We invest in three main silos ‐‐
real estate, auto dealerships,
and the fitness space.
Today, we manage over
15,000 apartment units,
and we employ over 600 people.
I went from
the New York Yankees team
to my A‐ROD CORP team,
and that's my happy zone.
Alright, here we go, girls.
Family's everything to me,
and especially being a father.
I know the impact that it left
on me when my father left us,
and it's really important for me
to not only be a great father,
but to be a present father.
The common theme
through my entire life ‐‐
I've always had doubters.
It's something
that's fueled me.
In business, you're always
gonna fight the stigma of,
"You're just an athlete."
But some of the biggest factors
in my success has been
the ability not to be defined
by my mistakes,
to continue to get back up,
to persevere.
It's funny.
I keep talking about business,
and it sounds like
I'm talking about baseball,
but they are very
similar to a degree.
Remember, baseball is
a competition of discipline.
I'm proud to be
the first Hispanic Shark.
We have over 60
million Hispanics
who spend over $1 trillion
in the U. S. economy.
That's the type of work we need
from you in the classroom,
on the baseball field,
when your parents
are talking to you.
What I tell
the next generation is,
you don't have to dunk
a basketball or hit home runs.
You can also chase your dreams
through education.
So, am I understood?
‐Yes, sir.
Let's go.
Rodriguez: You can be
an entrepreneur,
you can be a great businessman,
and I hope to inspire
a lot of people,
and especially people
in my community.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a tool
to soothe a common pain.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Ehan Kamat.
And I'm his dad,
Vinay Kamat.
We're from St. Louis,
Missouri,
and our product
is the Solemender.
We're seeking $75,000 in
exchange for 10% of our company.
Now, Sharks,
as a teenager,
I know a thing or two
about foot pain.
You see, I get up at 5:00 a. m.
for school,
and after a long day
of AP classes,
I shoot over
to the robotics lab,
after which I come home to tend
to my hydroponic garden.
So after all this,
my dogs are barking.
I think all you guys
can relate.
After a long day at work,
we need something portable
that can give us
quick foot relief.
So, I invented
the Solemender ‐‐
an innovative new
treatment solution
to help alleviate
foot pain.
Now, Ms. Corcoran,
when you were first
starting out as a waitress,
I would imagine that you would
have experienced some foot pain.
Would you mind coming up
and giving the Solemender a try?
I would love it if I get
some kind of massage out of it.
Exactly, right?
Come on over.
Yeah, I'm coming.
We have a seat set up
for you right here.
Good.
And what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna pull the frozen roller
out of the freezer
real quick.
Nice.
So, we have this guy right here,
which is our frozen roller.
And we're gonna take this, and
we're gonna put it in the base.
Now, it's as simple as rolling
your foot on the Solemender.
And we recommend 10
to 15 minutes twice a day.
‐Is it cold?
‐You feel cold?
It's only cold,
it's, like, instantly,
my foot relaxed ‐‐
It's shocking.
Yeah.
And what it's doing...
‐Really?
‐Wow.
‐Ba‐bam.
Wow,
I do feel refreshed.
It does.
It feels great, doesn't it?
Thank you for that.
Ehan: So, what the Solemender
is doing is,
it has
a stainless‐steel roller
with a proprietary
gel pack inside.
What it's doing is,
it's combining cold
and massage therapy
into one easy‐to‐use device.
Now, Sharks, who's ready
to help us mend some soles?
Ehan: Actually, I have
some samples for you guys
if you want
to check them out.
So, they are cold
so you can try them out.
‐Oh, they're cold. All right.
‐Perfect.
‐Terrific.
‐They are frozen.
And then, there's a piece
of packaging right there
so you can check out
how that runs, as well.
Corcoran: Nice.
And then, Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Ehan.
Thank you.
Ehan: So, what it's gonna do is,
it's gonna reduce inflammation
and it's also gonna help
repair micro‐tears
in the tendons that run along
the bottom of your foot.
‐How old are you?
‐I'm 17.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Plantar fasciitis ‐‐
I see that's right on the box.
Ehan: Yes.
Can you explain what this is,
and why this helps it?
So, what plantar fasciitis is,
is where you get micro tears
in the tendons that run along
the bottom of your foot,
and, unfortunately,
2 million people per year
get this condition,
and my mom was one
of those 2 million people.
I hated seeing her in pain,
so I figured
there's got to be
a way to help her out.
And it turns out that doctors
recommend freezing
a water bottle
and rolling your foot on it,
but if you've ever
frozen a water bottle,
you know it has the tendency
to explode every once
in a while.
So, I figured there's got
to be a better way
to help people alleviate
their foot pain,
but also be simple
and easy to use.
So I came up
with the Solemender,
and what happened was,
my dad,
and he is a little bit
of an expert
compared to me
on plantar fasciitis.
Why is Dad an expert?
So, I'm an internal
medicine physician,
been doing it
for about 20 years.
His mom, my wife,
is a rheumatologist,
and she does arthritis,
musculoskeletal disease,
and so forth.
So, he came up to us
with this idea, and we said,
"Uh, it sounds great.
But it's got to have been done."
Wasn't done.
We use marbles.
The Mavs use marbles.
Right.
So, people use marbles,
people use coffee cans,
people use golf balls.
I think I have
your first client.
I play with a guy
named Ichiro
who's gonna go straight
into the Hall of Fame,
and every day
for about an hour,
he would sit there in front
of his locker and do this...
for 45 minutes.
On what?
And then he went out
and got four hits every night.
Wait, what was he
doing that on?
What on ‐‐
on a device like this?
He used, like,
a little golf ball.
Oh, I was wondering.
What are your sales?
So, we've done $25,000
in just under a year,
and it's been a lot of me
going door‐to‐door,
talking to all these
different people.
We've been very fortunate
that 11 stores were
really, really excited
about the Solemender,
really excited about young
entrepreneurs and all that.
Have they re‐ordered
them from you?
Yes.
Yes, so we will get
a re‐order depending
on how sales are in the season
every one to two weeks.
And what are you selling
them for? I don't think
you gave us a price.
Yeah, so, they're sold
for $39.99.
Wow, that's pricey.
O'Leary: What do they
cost to make?
Right now, landed cost
is just under $10,
but if we can get
25,000 units,
we can get it down
to $6.80 landed here.
The biggest challenge
for this deal to me is,
how do I find the people
that have the highest propensity
to buy it...
Yeah.
...to get my
customer‐acquisition cost down,
because not everybody
wants this or needs it,
but the people that do need it
really want it.
Right.
So, 2 million people
have plantar fasciitis.
‐2 million.
‐2 million?
‐Per year.
Wait, I want to talk
about you a little bit,
because I don't want
to bury the headline.
I mean, the fact
that you're 17 years old.
When I was a 10‐year‐old boy,
I had two dreams.
I wanted to be
a Major League Baseball player,
and I wanted to be a CEO
of a major company.
What is it that you want
to do when you grow up?
So, I'll just real quick
start out with ‐‐
this moment right here
has been one of the greatest
moments of my life.
Honestly, I've watched
"Shark Tank"
since I was 8 years old ‐‐
Not yet, Ehan.
[ Laughter ]
Very true, very true.
What grade are you in?
I'm going into
senior year.
Where are you going
to school for college?
You know,
I'm not sure yet.
If I can get the Solemender
to where I need it to be,
I'm 100% committed
to the Solemender.
‐No, bad idea. Bad idea.
‐Whoa, whoa. Whoa!
Ehan, that's a bad idea,
and I'm gonna tell you why.
Learning accounting,
learning finance,
learning marketing ‐‐
the more you can
pull together,
the quicker you can
make decisions,
the more competitive you can be,
the greater the advantage.
O'Leary: There is the dilemma.
Who's gonna be
running Solemender?
You can run this
off the net,
and you're smart enough
to hire somebody to
go to all the doctor's offices
and grow it from there.
Learn!
Learn, learn, learn.
The greatest competitive
advantage is knowledge.
Rodriguez:
Ehan, you know what?
We used to say the only way
out of the hood
is to hit home runs
or get an education.
I want to get down
to the core issue.
What do you know
that could help any Shark
help you
acquire those customers?
So, I give you $75,000.
Task 1 is get me
2 million suffering.
So, if we get into
a retail store,
what do people do
when they have foot pain?
They run into their pharmacy
and they say,
"I don't want to go
to the doctor."
Yeah, but it's in retail
stores already, right?
I just want to sell it online.
All right.
Yeah.
But what are you
doing online, Ehan?
So, we do have
our online website.
Customer acquisition online
is the whole deal.
I got it.
That's what's missing
in this presentation.
And so, I don't know
that answer.
For me, it's an unknown.
That's what was missing,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Corcoran: Okay, Ehan,
I think you as a presenter
are phenomenal.
I think your product itself
lacks sex appeal.
It just doesn't
hook me in.
I love you,
but I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
I think that you will
go really far.
For me, this isn't
the right product for me.
[ Quietly ] No, don't go!
So, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
♪♪
Cuban: You remind me
a lot of me.
I mean, my earliest memories
are repackaging baseball cards
and selling them.
You have that same
type of drive,
but I would be devastated
if you didn't go to college.
Now, you could do all this
out of your dorm room,
and that's what I did.
As I learned things
in college,
I applied them
to different business ideas,
and I got better
and smarter,
and I had created greater
advantages for myself.
I think you have
to get there first.
Yeah.
Then it becomes
investable,
but for those reasons,
right now,
I'm out.
♪♪
Mr. Rodriguez we ‐‐
Go ahead.
Mr. Rodriguez, please,
we need to work
with somebody
who can get us
to the next level.
We see the sports market as
a big market for this.
To be quite honest ‐‐
and I'm conflicted,
because I am one that
invests in jockeys,
not horses,
and you are
the ultimate jockey.
But, at this point, it's just
too small of a business.
And because I really feel that
you should be going to college,
that's exactly what I would
tell my two daughters,
for that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, thank you.
Listen,
don't look discouraged.
And by the way,
I'll give you my card.
When you get out of college,
please call me
and let me know
what's next.
‐For sure, thank you.
‐All right?
‐Thanks guys.
‐Congrats.
‐Wow.
‐That's impressive.
Yeah, definitely.
Hard to make money.
No. He'll make money.
Ehan: Mark said that knowledge
is the competitive advantage,
and I think that's
fantastic advice.
I'm gonna pursue
moving into college.
You know, I'm only 17,
but this has been one
of the greatest
experiences for me,
and, you know, I have a lot
of advice to move forward now.
♪♪
NARRATOR: Next into The Tank
is a better version
of a ubiquitous
workout necessity.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name is Chris,
I'm from Dallas, Texas...
Yeah!
...and my company is Ice Shaker.
I'm here seeking $100,000
for 10% ownership in my company.
Sharks, as you can tell,
I work out.
♪♪
Growing up in a family
of five boys,
being the shortest meant
I had to be the strongest.
Anyone that hits the gym knows
what a shaker bottle
is all about,
and I was no exception.
I had cabinets full of them,
and they were all
exactly the same ‐‐
A cheap, plastic,
uninsulated bottle
that would either leak, break,
or smell awful
after a couple months.
So, I fixed all these problems.
Introducing the Ice Shaker.
The Ice Shaker is a double‐wall,
vacuum‐insulated shaker bottle
that will hold ice for over
30 hours in a 75‐degree room.
Insulated bottle does not sweat,
and here's my favorite part.
The Ice Shaker is
a kitchen‐grade stainless steel,
so it doesn't absorb odor.
So, here today with me,
to help demonstrate the product
are some people
you might recognize.
Bros!
[ All shouting ]
Wow! [ Laughs ]
Oh, Lord.
Sharks, meet my brothers.
Gordie, Dan, Rob,
and Glenn Gronkowski.
Together, we are...
Corcoran: Oh, my God.
All: The Gronks.
Wow.
Sharks, after a good,
hard pump session,
we like to get hydrated,
and we like to drink
protein shakes.
And the Gronk way
of getting this done,
is with a game of flip cup.
Today, we're playing
for the "Shark Tank"
Ice Shaker Championship Cup.
Now, the rules are easy.
The first team to drink
the water in the cup
and flip the cup over wins,
and the losers ‐‐
well, they got to drink a warm
shake out of one of the cheap,
plastic, sweaty
bottles over there.
[ Laughs ]
Today, we're playing 5‐on‐5.
Gronks vs. Sharks.
Whoo!
Let's go!
Mark's taking his shirt off.
I didn't know
it involved us.
Scary.
‐What up, big dog?
‐Mark, what's up, buddy?
‐How you doing?
‐Nice to meet you.
Congrats, champ.
Good seeing you, man.
Hello ‐‐ Rob.
how you doing?
What are the rules again?
What are we doing?
Yeah, what are we doing?
Okay, so after you
drink the water,
you flip the cup over.
Once it lands upside
down like that,
then the next person
can drink and start.
And then it's a relay
from this point on.
‐Okay.
‐We ready?
Okay, here we go.
Cheers.
‐Chug it, Alex.
‐
Chug, chug...
[ Chuckles ]
[ Cheers ]
‐Oh!
‐Let's go, bro!
‐Yeah!
‐[ Cheering ]
‐One flip!
‐Aw, you ruined it.
[ Laughter ]
[ All cheering ]
[ Indistinct chatter ]
‐Come on, you can take it.
‐Just go, just go!
♪♪
‐Oh!
‐[ Chuckles ]
[ Cheering ]
They're the pros.
[ Laughs ]
Hoo! Hoo! Hoo!
[ Laughing ]
Chris: Can we pass these out.
We had a good idea
that we were gonna win,
so we got you guys
a prize anyways.
Rob: Can I keep this one,
actually?
The classic,
stainless steel.
Here we go.
O'Leary: Tell us about
your million dollar
thermos bottle, here.
All right, so ‐‐
Wait, before we get
too far ahead, guys.
For all those people
watching who don't know
the Gronkowski family ‐‐
Super Bowl champs, right?
How many rings
do you guys have?
Well, I got two
Super Bowl Championships
with the
New England Patriots.
My brother, Glenn,
was with us this year, too.
Gord has a couple rings
playing baseball.
Yeah.
Unbelievable. Your parents
must be bursting with pride.
Greiner: Yeah.
It's really amazing.
Could you imagine.
You're worth feeding
all those years.
That's for sure.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, Chris, there's dozens
of these on the market.
So, there's nothing on the
market with the classic pop‐top
that is insulated
in stainless steel.
There was other bottles out
there that were stainless steel,
but didn't have a vacuum seal,
and they weren't double‐walled,
so when you touched them
or you put cold in it,
you would freeze
your hand.
Cuban: So, when did you start
the business side of it?
Have you started
to sell them?
Yes, In the first six months,
we've sold about $80,000 worth.
That's not bad.
And out of that $80,000,
$35,000 has been so far
this month and last month.
And where are you
selling them at?
So, right now, we're selling
them on our website,
We're selling them on Amazon.
We're in a few retail stores.
And we sell them
at fitness expos.
What's the retail price
of the bottle?
So, the bottle is $25.
What was the cost?
And your cost of making it?
Our cost to make them are
right around $5 landed.
Our margins are huge.
At retail, they're 80%.
Rodriguez: What
competitive advantage
do you feel like you have
over others?
I'm first‐to‐market
with it.
We already have
great reviews online.
The product's selling itself.
We put very little marketing
money into it at all.
Why is your name
not on it?
Uh, I wanted to build a product
that people wanted.
I didn't want it to be,
you know, every time
Rob posted it,
it sold and that was it.
I wanted make sure it was
something out there.
But couldn't you call it,
like, the Gronk‐shaker?
‐Right?
‐Yeah, she's right.
I mean, everybody'd be like,
"Yes, that's the one."
To Lori's point, right,
whatever edge you can get,
you got to take.
It already sounds right,
doesn't it?
‐Yeah.
‐The Gronk Shaker?
Chris, what do you need
the $100,000 for?
So, I don't exactly
need the money.
If I needed just $100,000,
I could probably
call someone I know,
and he'd probably
give it to me.
But, uh...
I need the expertise.
I like it, 'cause
I'm a huge Gronk fan.
I love your family,
I love the team,
I'm from Boston,
it's cool.
But I want to make money ‐‐
I'm a Shark.
Well, see, all right, look.
If you can bring
the "Gronk" into it,
I'll do the deal for 20%.
I'll give you 100k for 20%.
♪♪
Rodriguez: Chris,
I love the back story.
You know, I own part of
a thousand gyms in 20 countries.
I understand athletes,
so when we see entrepreneurs
stand on that rug
and you're an athlete,
I feel like you're a guy coming
into the Yankee clubhouse,
and you're a guy that
I want in the foxhole with me.
'Cause I think you're
a championship player.
I am interested ‐‐
Mark, if you're interested,
I think we can bring
a lot to this business.
Oh, no question.
Corcoran: No, no, no.
Well, I have an offer, too.
Well, is there an offer
or is it just talk?
Is 10% enough?
10% is not enough.
Right,
that's the challenge.
Chris, you've got
to start thinking
how much value
we can add.
♪♪
‐So, what's your offer?
I think what makes sense,
Alex, is make it 150k for 20%.
You're raising the dollars
by 50,000.
Yeah, 'cause the amount
gives us both a reason
to get excited and help.
You can go to the Yankees,
You can go
to your fitness clubs,
We can put it in
the Mavs locker room.
So, 150k.
So, your offer...
150k for 20%,
but we don't
like to wait around.
♪♪
Got to give me an answer
right now.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Chris Gronkowski has
two offers on the table
for his insulated
protein shake bottle,
Ice Shaker.
Kevin has offered
$100,000 for 20%.
Mark and Alex have joined in
on an offer of $150,000 for 20%.
Chris, we don't like
to wait around.
So you got to tell us.
No, he's afraid of
the ladies sitting here.
You've got to tell us.
Corcoran: Frankly, guys,
I would give you
a million dollars for 10%.
Wow.
Just to hang out
with you guys.
[ Laughter ]
I don't care
what the deal is.
Okay, on a more
serious note,
definitely take
Lori's great idea
and change the name
immediately.
I think it should be
in big, capital, bold,
raised letters
that just says "Gronk."
Here's my offer ‐‐
$100,000 for
10% of the business.
Nobody's smarter than me
at marketing,
and I've done it with already
seven of my top brands
that wouldn't be where they are
from "Shark Tank"
if not for
my marketing ability.
They're all big brands
in their space.
Listen, I haven't even gotten
to get out my offer yet.
I want to show you
my references.
A scroll
from the 1600s.
So, Scrub Daddy ‐‐
$120 million.
Simply Fit ‐‐
$150 million.
Sleep Styler ‐‐
$75 million in four months.
I've taken
multiple companies
to multi‐billion‐dollar
valuations, all right?
My offer is ‐‐
How many have you
done, Lori?
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Whoa, whoa, whoa ‐‐
I have taken people
to many, many, many millions
instantly.
Lori! What's the offer?
What's the offer?
Simply Fit Board
is a household name.
Lori, what's your offer?
I'm gonna go
$100,000 for 15%.
♪♪
Okay, now.
We have four offers ‐‐
an extraordinary outcome
of "Shark Tank" ‐‐
very rare.
♪♪
What are you going to do?
I appreciate
all the offers...
I want to ask if Lori would join
in with Mark and Alex.
I wouldn't do that.
Oh.
Wow, well, you know,
Mark answered that...
The answer is "no."
...but I didn't hear
what Alex had to say.
Would you take me in
and maybe lose Mark?
Here's the thing.
I gave Mark my word,
so I got to stand by that,
so I'm gonna back
my partner on this one.
So, Lori just got
thrown under the bus.
What are you going to do?
I'm pretty firm
with the valuation.
Would you guys do
the $150,000 for 15%?
♪♪
Yeah, we'll do it.
You got a deal, baby!
[ All cheering ]
Whoo!
Football, basketball,
and baseball, baby.
What's up, baby?
How you doing?
‐Careful.
‐1, 2, 3!
[ All shout ]
[ Laughter ]
All: Hoo! Hoo! Hoo! Hoo! Hoo!
Hoo! Hoo! Hoo! Hoo! Hoo!
Congrats, Alex.
How about that?
Yeah, congrats, Alex.
‐Thank you.
‐Very good, very good.
Let me ask you ‐‐
what did I do wrong there?
This is just an industry
we're very close to,
and, Alex,
I didn't even know he has gyms.
I mean, this will
do great at my gyms.
He was very fair.
And I tell you what,
we are gonna blow it up.
We just locked up
the tri‐fecta.
The NFL, NBA, and baseball ‐‐
That's absolutely huge.
And I'm so pumped right now.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a modern way
to keep your belongings safe.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Robbie Cabral.
I'm the inventor, CEO,
and founder of BenjiLock.
I come to the Tank
extremely humble,
seeking $200,000
for 10% of my company.
Sharks, I go to the gym
every day.
Try to keep myself in shape,
but also release
that grind and stress.
Ironically,
I noticed that stress
was actually lurking
in the locker rooms.
People actually knocking
on their locker doors
because they left
their keys inside,
others actually forgot
their combinations.
They were stressed out,
and that's why I created
BenjiLock.
BenjiLock is the world's first
traditional padlock
with fingerprint technology,.
Wow.
...which means that not
only you can open it
with the ease of
your fingertips...
[ Whirring ]
Wow.
But also...
Clever.
...with a set
of traditional keys.
So, if the technology fails,
you're still able
to use your lock.
Now, Sharks, who wants
to lock up this deal
and invest in BenjiLock?
[ Chuckles ]
What I'm gonna show you
right now,
it's the evolution of BenjiLock,
which is, uh,
it's a dummy version.
Greiner: So, is this
a prototype?
Yes, right now,
it's a prototype.
I'm working on
a smaller version, as well.
O'Leary: How long
will it hold a charge
before I have
to use the key?
You charge it
for 30 minutes,
and it lasts you
a whole year.
A year?
A year with one,
single charge.
Wow.
With God's faith,
I just got the patent granted.
‐Wow.
‐Great, congrats.
I see you won
the CES Award.
You won the Innovation Award
for 2017.
Yes.
Well, the Consumer
Electronics Show
is full of people
and innovators displaying
the newest technology
and innovation.
Everybody comes
from all over the world
to go to it to see
what's the latest greatest.
So, it's very impressive to me
that you won that,
so that speaks
volumes.
Can it also be
used as a patent
to replace
the core‐cylinder lock
in the standard
domestic door‐lock?
Yep, yep.
Okay, Robbie.
I'm imagining that when people
saw this innovation ‐‐
particularly large,
lock manufacturers ‐‐
did they approach you
and say,
"Robbie, I'd like to
license your technology"?
There's one right now
that's just waiting
for me to take action.
How much is it gonna
cost to make it,
and what's it gonna cost
at retail?
I did a survey in L. A.
with 1,041 people
with just the prototype,
and I told them,
"Are you willing to buy this?"
if it's on the shelf,
and they all say ‐‐ 99.
9 say "yes."
They haven't see‐‐
Did you read my book?
I...
[ Chuckles ]
I was gonna say,
"That's what I say to do."
Good job.
They told me that
they're willing to pay
$60 or more for the lock.
And what can you
make it for?
I can get this lock
at $20.
At what quantity were
you quoted?
At 50,000 units.
50,000 units.
50,000 at $20.
50,000 units because
I have Sam's Club interested
in 30,000 units
for Q1 of 2018.
Corcoran: Robbie, where did you
get the money to start this?
It must be expensive
to do a prototype.
Yeah, I mean,
I did it all on my own ‐‐
self‐funded.
How much money
did you put into it?
Right now...
I've invested $87,000.
‐Wow.
Cuban: People always think
they have to go raise money,
borrow money,
but the one thing in life
you can control
is your effort.
Yeah.
Is this your full‐time gig,
Robbie?
This is my full‐time job.
I've been working on this
since I got laid off from work,
so I guess this own work.
My wife is a teacher.
I got three kids.
I was born and raised
in Dominican Republic.
Nuh‐uh!
I came in 2007.
So I'm gonna tell you,
my friends, dude,
I mean...
it's been a long journey.
My background
is marketing/advertising,
and when I actually tried to
"make the American Dream"
and had a good job
in the real estate world,
six months into it,
I got laid off.
And the day they laid me off,
my daughter was born.
Wow.
[ Voice breaking ] So, now,
you know, you're unemployed.
You thought that
you came to America
to make the American Dream.
I got laid off,
I said, "Man,
I'm just gonna try to push it
for my family, for my friends."
[ Sniffles ]
It's just that...
a lot of people never
believe in you, man.
A lot of people
said to me, like,
"Oh, you're not
gonna make it."
But, all of a sudden,
I had something great.
And now I'm here, man.
For me, this is
the American Dream already.
O'Leary: I'm trying
to figure out if you want to go
the partnership route
with a giant,
global distributor.
Because if you want to do that,
I'm your guy.
I'm a beast
on licensing deals.
And so I'll make you
an offer.
♪♪
I'll give you
the $200,000 for 15%,
and because you're
the control partner,
I'll bring the best
deal forward,
but you ultimately make
the decision.
What often happens
is an inventor like you
brings it to a giant partner,
and they bury it.
They license it from you.
They never bring it to market.
That's not true.
‐That's what you want to avoid.
‐That's often true.
‐It's a fact.
I actually agree with Kevin
on this one.
I don't agree at all.
It's rare that I do,
but...
because when something's
really innovative,
a big company will come in,
give you a license,
but then bury it
because it's competition.
That's the game
in licensing,
is forcing your partner
to deliver.
Robbie, I see
your brows furrowing
like you're getting worried
like you're listening to him.
Don't listen to him.
That is just ridiculous.
Listen, that's an offer.
It's ridiculous.
If you want to go
that direction,
then you'll have cash
flow every quarter.
Every 90 days,
you'll get a check
to do other things with.
I mean, it's an interesting
path of the licensing,
'cause I know that
through that invention,
there's other things
that I can create.
I don't see the vision
the same as Kevin, okay?
I see the vision is that
you don't have to make a choice
between licensing and retail
and manufacturing.
If you want to go into retail,
I'll go there with you, too.
But I think you want
to pursue both paths,
because you're a year
and a half, two years away
from actually
delivering this product.
‐You know what, Robbie ‐‐
‐Robbie.
Wait, I'm gonna give you
an offer, okay?
So, I'm going to offer you
the $200,000 for 15%.
‐Same as Kevin.
‐Identical deal.
‐Okay, Robbie.
You know what I think you need
more than a partner?
I think you need a team.
So I'm going to give you
one‐half of the $200,000
for 10% of the business,
but you're gonna have
to get another Shark
to join me on that.
'Cause I think you really need
your own little board
of directors
that helps you
along the way,
and I don't think
Kevin's kind of a deal
is really
what you want.
Creative people don't want
those kind of deals.
They want to birth
their baby
and they want to
bring it to fruition
and get the satisfaction
of seeing it grow up.
That's just the way it is.
Lori and I both gave him
a better offer than you.
First of all,
let me just tell you,
as someone who both of
his parents are Dominican,
I lived in Dominican
from age 5 to about 9.
And I just love your passion.
I love what you're doing.
And I cannot tell you
how proud I am.
Everything that you've done
resonates with me.
It's just
an amazing story.
So, you had me at hello.
[ Sniffles ]
Ah!
No, no.
Corcoran: Me gusta mucho.
He asked 20%
for with Barbara,
because I can speak
Spanish, too.
[ Cuban and Rodriguez laugh ]
So, so ‐‐ wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Bonjour, mes amis.
[ Chuckles ]
I can speak French.
Okay, I'm gonna
stop in Spanish.
So...
Robbie, look.
I think what you've been able
to accomplish is phenomenal.
You're a grinder,
you're heart, you're passion,
but I'm not the right person
to just go out and license this,
'cause it's tech,
but it's not really tech,
and so for those reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Robbie. Lori ‐‐
There's no question.
She's the best of the best
at what she does.
She has QVC,
and she's phenomenal.
No, don't say "QVC."
Lori, please stop groveling.
I'm all over retail,
I'm all over TV.
Here's what we have.
And I'm all over
the Internet.
I speak your
native language,
I understand you better than
any other Shark here.
Robbie, you've got
to make a decision.
I see your pain, but you've
got to make a decision.
This is not a bad problem
you're having.
This is a good day
No, it's a good problem.
It's a good problem
to have right now.
Oh, Lord Jesus.
Santo Dios.
[ Chuckles ]
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
You've got three amazing offers,
and now it's your time.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Robbie has three offers
on the table
for his biometric padlock,
BenjiLock.
Kevin and Lori have both offered
$200,000 for 15%,
and Barbara and Alex together
have offered $200,000 for 20%.
What do you want to do?
Let's do this, Robbie.
No, Robbie.
Let's do this.
Stop whining ‐‐
both of you.
My gut is telling me
a lot of things right now.
This is very difficult
to choose.
I mean, all of you guys
are great,
I mean, holy smokes.
Oh, Lord Jesus,
santo Dios.
[ Groans ]
Gosh, I love all of you,
but for some reason,
my heart is telling me
to go with Mr. Wonderful.
What?!
Wow!
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God!
Yeah, you go, Robbie!
Shock of the century.
I didn't think
he had a shot.
You are money.
I'm gonna make you rich.
Watch it happen.
You got it, man.
I want to meet your wife, too.
Fantastic.
Thanks a lot.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
I'm so proud of you.
Felicidades.
Well, I'll eat my hat.
My God.
Thank you.
Gracias, gracias.
I went with Kevin because
I feel that he's a strong beast
at negotiating licensing,
and I felt like all
of their offers were great.
But just for some reason I felt
the fire that I saw in Kevin,
for some reason,
something connected there.
I know I made
the right decision.
Instinct that leads to you?
I don't get it.
Kevin, if he doesn't
blow up,
I'm gonna come find you
in Canada.
[ Both laugh ]
"Boom" goes the dynamite.